I'm in need of a shave and the village barber, Yohan,...
...is as skilled as a surgeon with a straight blade.
Oh good!
Come.
Thank you.
I would like my hair short and then shaved here and here, okay?
Okay.
And what the heck is this?
This feels, whoa! It's a little spicy hot.
My goodness. I feel I hear things burning.
I smell things burning.
It could be flesh burn, you know.
That's very nice and warm.
Very nice and warm.
Very good, yes!
I want more of this stuff.
Thank you.
No problem?
No, no problem. Thank you.
That's alright. You don't have to do that.
Thank you very very much.
Well, after many days at sea,...
...it feels good to be cleaned and shaved and hair cut, again.
And I'm not quite sure what that fire thing was and the crack in the knuckles.
My barber didn't do any of that back in the States.
I think we're gonna have to have a word with him.